Let us now put to use our
understanding of the
coin-tossing model and the
associated binomial
probabilities.
We will solve the following
problem.
We have a coin, which
is tossed 10 times.
And we're told that exactly
three out of the 10 tosses
resulted in heads.
Given this information, we would
like to calculate the
probability that the first
two tosses were heads.
This is a question of
calculating a conditional
probability of one event
given another.
The conditional probability of
event A, namely that the first
two tosses were heads, given
that another event B has
occurred, namely that we
had exactly three heads
out of the 10 tosses.
However, before we can start
working towards the solution
to this problem, we need to
specify a probability model
that we will be working with.
We need to be explicit about
our assumptions.
To this effect, let us introduce
the following
assumptions.
We will assume that the
different coin tosses are
independent.
In addition, we will assume
that each coin toss has a
fixed probability, p, the same
for each toss, that the
particular toss results
in heads.
These are the exact same
assumptions that we made
earlier when we derived the
binomial probabilities.
And in particular, we have the
following formula that if we
have n tosses, the probability
that we obtain exactly k heads
is given by this expression.
So now, we have a model in place
and also the tools that
we can use to analyze this
particular model.
Let us start working
towards a solution.
Actually, we will develop two
different solutions and
compare them at the end.
The first approach,
which is the
safest one, is the following.
Since we want to calculate a
conditional probability, let
us just start with the
definition of conditional
probabilities.
The conditional probability of
an event given another event
is the probability that both
events happen, divided by the
probability of the conditioning
event.
Now, let us specialize to the
particular example that we're
trying to solve.
So in the numerator, we're
talking about the probability
that event A happens and
event B happens.
What does that mean?
This means that event
A happens--
that is, the first two tosses
resulted in heads, which I'm
going to denote symbolically
this way.
But in addition to that,
event B happens.
And event B requires that there
is a total of three
heads, which means that we
had one more head in
the remaining tosses.
So we have one head in tosses
3 all the way to 10.
As for the denominator, let's
keep it the way it is for now.
So let's continue with
the numerator.
We're talking about the
probability of two events
happening, that the first two
tosses were heads and that in
tosses 3 up to 10, we had
exactly one head.
Here comes the independence
assumption.
Because the different tosses
are independent, whatever
happens in the first two tosses
is independent from
whatever happened in
tosses 3 up to 10.
So the probability of these two
events happening is the
product of their individual
probabilities.
So we first have the probability
that the first two
tosses were heads, which
is p squared.
And we need to multiply it
with the probability that
there was exactly one head
in the tosses numbered
from 3 up to 10.
These are eight tosses.
The probability of one head in
eight tosses is given by the
binomial formula, with k equal
to 1 and n equal to 8.
So this expression, this part,
becomes 8 choose 1, p to the
first power times 1 minus
p to the seventh power.
So this is the numerator.
The denominator is
easier to find.
This is the probability
that we had
three heads in 10 tosses.
So we just use this formula.
The probability of three heads
is given by: 10 tosses choose
three, p to the third, times 1
minus p to the seventh power.
And here we notice that terms
in the numerator and
denominator cancel out, and we
obtain 8 choose 1 divided by
10 choose 3.
And to simplify things
just a little more,
what is 8 choose 1?
This is the number of ways that
we can choose one item
out of eight items.
And this is just 8.
And let's leave the denominator
the way it is.
So this is the answer to the
question that we had.
And now let us work towards
developing a second approach
towards this particular
answer.
In our second approach, we start
first by looking at the
sample space and understanding
what
conditioning is all about.
In our model, we have
a sample space.
As usual we can denote
it by omega.
And the sample space contains a
bunch of possible outcomes.
A typical outcome is going to
be a sequence of length 10.
It's a sequence of
heads or tails.
And it's a sequence that
has length 10.
We want to calculate conditional
probabilities.
And this places us in a
conditional universe.
We have the conditioning event
B, which is some set.
And conditional probabilities
are probabilities defined
inside this set B and define
the probabilities, the
conditional probabilities of
the different outcomes.
What are the elements
of the set B?
A typical element of the set B
is a sequence, which is, again
of length 10, but has
exactly three heads.
So these are the three-head
sequences.
Now, since we're conditioning
on event B, we can just work
with conditional
probabilities.
So let us find the conditional
probability law.
Recall that any three-head
sequence has the same
probability of occurring in
the original unconditional
probability model, namely as
we discussed earlier, any
particular three-head sequence
has a probability equal to
this expression.
So three-head sequences are
all equally likely.
This means that the
unconditional probabilities of
all the elements of
B are the same.
When we construct conditional
probabilities given an event
B, what happens is that the
ratio or the relative
proportions of the probabilities
remain the same.
So conditional probabilities
are proportional to
unconditional probabilities.
These elements of B were
equally likely in
the original model.
Therefore, they remain equally
likely in the conditional
model as well.
What this means is that the
conditional probability law on
the set B is uniform.
Given that B occurred, all the
possible outcomes now have the
same probability.
Since we have a uniform
probability law, this means
that we can now answer
probability
questions by just counting.
We're interested in the
probability of a certain
event, A, given that
B occurred.
Now, given that B occurred, this
part of A cannot happen.
So we're interested in the
probability of outcomes that
belong in this shaded region,
those outcomes that belong
within the set B. To find the
probability of this shaded
region occurring, we just need
to count how many outcomes
belong to the shaded region and
divide them by the number
of outcomes that belong
to the set B.
That is, we work inside this
conditional universe.
All of the elements in this
conditional universe are
equally likely.
And therefore, we calculate
probabilities by counting.
So the desired probability is
going to be the number of
elements in the shaded region,
which is the intersection of A
with B, divided by the number of
elements that belong to the
set B.
How many elements are there in
the intersection of A and B?
These are the outcomes or
sequences of length 10, in
which the first two tosses
were heads--
no choice here.
And there is one more head.
That additional head can appear
in one out of eight
possible places.
So there's eight possible
sequences that have the
desired property.
How many elements are
there in the set B?
How many three-head sequences
are there?
Well, the number of three-head
sequences is the same as the
number of ways that we can
choose three elements out of a
set of cardinality 10.
And this is 10 choose 3, as
we also discussed earlier.
So this is the same answer as
we derived before with our
first approach.
So both approaches, of course,
give the same solution.
This second approach is a little
easier, because we
never had to involve any
p's in our calculation.
We go to the answer directly.
The reason that this approach
worked was that the
conditional universe, the
event B, had a uniform
probability law on it.